as you of course remember the supposed
murder of George Floyd was a wonderful
occasion for the media rarely have they
been able to manufacture a story so
potent and so useful it was great for
Ratings it was even better for the
narrative they could push leftwing
talking points while also raking in the
advertising dollars it was the best of
both worlds they loved it so it's
understandable in a certain way that the
media has been trying desperately ever
since then to recapture that same magic
to ignite the spark the spark that
ultimately burned down entire city
blocks all around the country and
they've been looking for their new
George Floyd all they've been able to
find at best though are you know little
George Floyd Juniors but they keep
searching they keep trying their best to
fabricate stories that might be as
ideologically and monetarily profitable
as the one they told about blessed Saint
George Floyd and they have tried again
with the latest BLM martyr a man named
Leonard cure uh this past Monday cure
was shot and killed by a deputy in
Camden County Georgia after he was
pulled over for a traffic stop uh there
are only three pieces of information
about this incident that the that the
media wants you to focus on or wants you
to know at all and uh this is the first
piece that cure was shot during a
traffic stop the second is that cure was
black and the third is that he was
recently exonerated and released from
prison after serving 16 years on an
armed robbery charge here's the New York
Times with those details quote Mr cure
was convicted of the armed robbery of a
wall of the Walgreens in Broward county
in 2003 and was sentenced to life in
prison because of Prior convictions in
2020 the Broward state attorney's office
conviction revieww unit asked a judge to
release mure after the unit found
problems with the case according to the
South Florida Sun
Sentinel these in uh concerns included
how a suspect was identified and the
fact that an alibi from Mr cure was
never presented in court Mr cure was
released and in December 2020 he was
exonerated based on findings of actual
innocence the Innocence Project of
Florida said officials had determined
that evidence in the form of an ATM
receipt had proven that Mr cure was
miles from the crime scene at the time
of the robbery now um if Mr cure was
falsely convicted that's very
unfortunate it's also not relevant at
all to what happened during the traffic
stop on Monday the officer didn't know
about that history and even if he had it
wouldn't have changed anything in the
moment and yet nearly every media
headline on this shooting is framed like
this this is from the same New York
Times article this is the headline man
wrongfully imprisoned for 16 years is
fatally shot during traffic stop here's
NPR Leonard cure freed after a wrong
wrongful conviction is shot dead in a
traffic stop CNN says a wrongfully
convicted man who was exonerated after
16 years is shot and killed during
traffic stop you get the idea let's take
the least relevant fact and put it in
the headline that's the strategy this is
how the narrative is cemented before
anyone even knows exactly what happened
or why and local media of course is on
the same page here's how they're
covering the story watch tonight those
who knew Leonard cure tell 11 alive that
they're still in disbelief tonight 11
Alive's Cody Alcorn picks up our team
coverage tonight from downtown Atlanta
he's live outside of the Georgia
Innocence Project and Cody how did that
nonprofit and Leonard cure cross
paths Jennifer Ron shortly after being
released in April 2020 Leonard moved to
Georgia where he became part of Georgia
innocent projects free and exonerated
community turn around 17 days before
Leonard cure was shot during a traffic
stop in Camden County the 53-year-old
who trusted an a wrongful arrest before
and wasn't released for 16 years spoke
to a group of students at Jonesboro High
School one of the things that uh he
really harped on when he spoke to the
students during his original arrest in
2003 he was very compliant with the the
police Christian steall helped prep
Leonard for for his speech really
getting to know him I can only imagine
what was going through his mind when um
he was poured over again so that's all
we need to know right he was a black man
wrongfully convicted he was going around
and giving talks to high school students
clearly his death is a great Injustice
and outrage who cares about the actual
details well the ACLU of Florida
certainly doesn't they tweeted yesterday
Leonard cure was incarcerated for a
crime he didn't commit for 16 years
before getting his life snatched from
him by a cop modern policing is rooted
in slavery and rotten to the Core the
Southern Poverty Law Center agrees
posting splc is deeply saddened by the
tragic loss of Leonard cure in Camden
County Georgia we urgently call for a
transformation in policing that honors
every individual's rights the ongoing
anti-blackness in policing must end
every leader must act for justice and
accountability so anti-blackness and
policing modern policing is rooted in
slavery Leonard cure was just released
from prison he was a nice man his
friends and family loved him we've heard
a lot of things but we haven't heard
what actually happened and if you're a
credulous a member of the
brainless mob then you have enough
information to have already formed an
opinion because it's the opinion the
media has formed for you but if you have
a working brain that functions
independently from the hive mind then
you may be interested to see the footage
of the altercation which the Camden
County Sheriff's office has
released here it is St
out get
out get out put your hands back here I
ain't
doing put your damn hands back here who
are you staff's Serge Sheriff's Office
my name is I don't care step to the rear
of this vehicle in the name of who in
the name of the law of the state of
Georgia step back here now you're
getting
tased I'm going watch me now put your
hands on the back of that truck do you
see that put your hands on the back of
that truck the back of the truck both
hands turn around
34 K send me another unit one non
[Music]
compliant your name is officer who staff
sergeant alge with the cam County
Sheriff's Office county Camden County
put your hand behind your back do I have
a do I have a warrant wait wait no no no
no no wa no no no no excuse me excuse me
either put your hands behind your back
CU you're getting tased I'm telling you
that right now why am I getting tased
cuz you are under arrest for speeding
and was driving I'm not driving nobody
was hurt how was I speed you pass me
doing 100 mph okay so that's a speeding
ticket right okay let's pause it there
for a moment um how was I speeding he
asks after going 100 miles an
hour uh and I know it's not really funny
but there
is it's a little funny that part of the
exchange how was I speeding you're going
100 miles an hour oh well yeah except
for going 100 miles an hour how was I
speeding
in the state of Georgia and in pretty
much every other state going 100 miles
hour is a crime it's reckless driving
and there's a good reason to prosecute
it as a crime because at that speed the
likelihood of getting into an accident
is very high and the likelihood that
everyone involved will die is nearly
100% okay going 100 miles hour down the
road and you come up against traffic
that has slowed down someone you know
Cuts in front of you anything like that
you're not going to have re the time to
react and you're going to kill everybody
involved in the
accident that's why it's a crime the
point here is that cure is being pulled
over and arrested for committing a crime
and a dangerous crime at that all he has
to do now all he should do all that any
rational and halfway decent person would
do is cooperate and accept the
consequences of your
actions that's it you broke the law you
got caught game
over that's really your only viable
Choice it's also the right choice but it
wasn't Leonard Cure's
Choice uh let's keep watching Sir tiets
in the state of Georgia are criminal
offenses I don't have a ticket in
Georgia you do now why you pass me doing
100 miles and what I'm not going ja
hands behind your back yes you going to
jail hands behind your
back put your hands behind your
[Music]
back
yeah
yeah okay so uh let's review uh Leonard
cure decided to go 100 miles hour he got
pulled over the officer tried to arrest
him for the crime he just committed cure
was uncooperative from the very start
Kure refused to do as he was told the
officer tried to use a Taser but then
Kor assaulted him the officer tried
wrestling Kure to the ground then he
tried using a baton on cure kept
assaulting him finally the officer used
his gun and cure stopped assaulting him
if you're keeping track if you're
keeping track at home the officer used
literally every non-lethal means at his
disposal before finally resorting to
lethal means he even continued using
non-lethal means while he was being
physically attacked personally if I have
any objection to the way the officer
conducted himself is that he was he was
far too nice he should have shot him
sooner if I was in that position I would
have shot him I would have shot him dead
the second he put his hands on
me but then again the officer knows from
the moment a black suspect starts being
non-compliant that he's in a lose lose
situation he's fully aware that if he
has to defend himself his life will be
destroyed and he might go to prison and
if he doesn't defend himself he might be
killed on the spot which means that even
while a cop is literally fighting for
his life he has to be thinking about how
this will look on camera after the fact
I mean it's insane that police have been
put in that position but that's the
position they're in and uh with all that
in mind I think this officer threaded
The Impossible needle in a rather
admirable
way but none of that matters to the Mob
or the media or for that matter the
family members who have this to say
watch C's family believes there was no
deescalation on either side it was uh
excitement met with excitement in result
I still believe in my heart and I know
in my heart my brother should be alive
Cure's family and his family attorney B
crub help a press conference Wednesday
which is when they saw the video Cure's
mother says she feels her son was
paranoid from already being wrongfully
incarcerated spending more than 16 years
in prison I can tell you this there was
nothing so bad that he deserve to
die uh yes there was ma'am he physically
assaulted a police officer who was
simply trying to do his job and enforce
the law in fact he continued assaulting
a police officer while three different
types of non-lethal measures were used
he did everything in his power to get
shot by a cop and he was so did he
deserve it
yes okay he didn't deserve to die yes he
did the same way you deserve to get
shocked if you stick a fork in an
electrical
outlet You Deserve The Logical and
inevitable consequences of your actions
if you don't deserve that then what does
the the word deserve mean you know maybe
rather than doing a press conference
with Ben Crump and throwing a police
officer under the bus for simply doing
his job maybe you should be reflecting
on how your son turned out this way keep
in mind that he was a habitual criminal
convicted of multiple crimes before his
arrest in
2003 so some introspection from the
family is in order but instead as usual
they cast blame everywhere
else now that said I agree with Cure's
brother he says that he knows in his
heart that Leonard should still be alive
and he's absolutely right he should
still be alive he threw his own life
away for
nothing first going 100 mes hour than
viciously assaulting a police officer
this man had a death
wish at the very least he was ambivalent
about his own
existence he didn't value his life or
his
freedom you know we keep hearing about
well he he didn't want to go back to
prison so why are you doing something
that assures you will go back to prison
the minute you start assaulting the cop
best case scenario is you go to prison
that's the best case worst case is you
die
there is no other potential
outcome so if he didn't want to go back
to prison why was he doing anything
thing that would
ensure with with absolute
certainty that at best he goes back to
prison in fact the officer he attacked
valued Cure's life more than cure did he
was clearly more committed to keeping
the man alive than the man himself
was why didn't C beli that his own life
mattered why was he willing to throw it
all away for Nothing by making a series
of choices that could have nothing but
negative outcomes for
him well that would be a worthwhile
conversation one that we should
eventually get around to having but
instead we're stuck in fantasy land
pretending that a bunch of violent
suicidal criminals are somehow victims
of a racist
conspiracy and this of course is the
fantasy land that the media has
constructed and it's why they are today
finally
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there